no I don't even know what I'm saying how
about noodles for you nobody will get in
here you know they will be afraid that I
will kill them you want to put a mirror
as an actor to help to see ourselves in
it for better or worse and my brother is
still alive as long as Versace is alive
being able to play the Nutella Versace
is that being able to to do my own
personal omage to her because I really
like Hollywood power couple Penelope
Cruz and Javier Bardem reflect on their
decades-long careers and the driving
force that helps them choose
award-winning roles do you want to leave
a message yes just kicked off a spanic
Heritage Month you've had such a
successful career what from your culture
and heritage has you know influenced you
to take on certain roles well I think
it's about really believing in what
you're doing and knowing or feeling at
least that what you're doing is gonna
have some impact on someone yeah you
know that you want to change the world
because that's what any art discipline
should do painting or music or sculpture
or movies or theater to talk about it
now what from your hair to type you pass
down to your kids I just want them to be
nice honest caring people we know that
it's not easy because then the world is
there and the world is a very complex
place to be but also very nice caring
beautiful place to to hold on to
well I think my parents tourists great
values you know about like they were
very hard workers they didn't take
anything for granted
they really value family a family has
always been a priority that's how I was
raised what I have always seen I don't
know any other way like family comes
first and then everything else
absolutely and when it comes to raising
your children you said you instilled
those values with when it comes to
family when are they gonna be able to
watch your films I know we want to
protect our kids as long as possible
yeah I haven't done a lot of films that
are for
children well I don't know I mean the
thing is they're very young so ya know
you don't have a restriction though just
like whenever they grow up and they see
it yeah em there are some someone that I
have done that maybe I don't know a ten
year all good works or a nine year old
but no but I'm I'm I'm looking I hope I
can do some animation work and I would
love to think I'm sure they'd enjoy that
I'd love to do some of that I tried to
get into frozen to that were they want
but no that would be needed there would
be you know yeah but yeah I haven't done
a lot of nice forget sister well it's
coming
[Music]